musée
bois pour la peau
reine des prunus contrat palus des mots
l'exposé erectus je roule ma boss green
car apple dans des circuits seraient des
phallus contre a fallu ce démon lesbos
direct du roule ma bouche fine carabosse
dans l'espace
la santé
l'accidenté
e
il a dérangé
euram amour
j'ai tous les noms je souligne que tous
les chronos mcj l'enseigné
dans la fureur de
voilà le con aujourd'hui de vieux os
vient ressac contourne le soir
le genre du si lumineux temps je fais
et
l'attenté
et ranger la déjantée
m
pendant douze jours
lee
maxime c'est pas grand
à
pas tous
rendez jamais trop peiné
avait trop fait
j'ai trop fait
des trophées
les trophées
je suis
voilà ma gloire
molesté
et mon soutien
mon chant d'amour et de l'histoire je
suis bd
c'était bien
merci henriette l'ouvrant on retrouve on
le retrouve tout à l'heure le rester